some people are exhausting and they
don't do the right thing at all it's a
Monday I just wrote the song I'm really
happy to be here you're back from
Cleveland from Cleveland you really
loved it um you were Indian yeah well
your shoes hurt my eyes your shoes hello
why they're so flimsy they know to give
it away no cuz you know what it is
you've ran them to the bottom I will
they're of my Wolverine thousand-mile
errs and I I split wood with him I do
man [ __ ] you pose in those don't you
shiny shears buddy how do you come as
Buzz Aldrin's what would you just wake
up and decide to put those on who my
house on the wrong oh no leave it done
oh they're so expensive
oh no yeah bro but are they designed by
NASA they expensive I don't know they
give them to you for [ __ ] I don't know
Brian I don't believe it I think you
spent crazy money on them when would I
I don't know it was out of town bro me
did it online yeah I think you broke out
I don't think so see if you can get
these online I want some silver shoes to
go with my space suit you'll learn one
day dude it's about being influenced sir
sure your figured out huh I'm too old
year old then I get I'm just too old
it's not you don't use a 52 year-old to
model your you just don't me yeah dude I
flew you love Cleveland no sir well it's
good time you got Nick who runs hilarity
zones hilarious legend you want to look
like him and you're his age gave me a
custom bat and it's already awesome and
he goes now we're gonna ship it to you
cuz you're way too big kids in the
airport on the plane they're gonna
arrest you so we're gonna ship it to you
now those are 720 dollar shoes even more
I can't find them I can't find them
we're so there you might be wearing a
thousand dollar pairs like sneakers Ryan
why you got kick it off like this dude
because it hurts my feelings makes me
mad and you'll wear them twice maybe hey
so
Cleveland great food people yeah great
great town and was I believe an oil town
or was it a steel town but either way
he'll tear it was some real money in
that area and at one point I was so
polluted that the river the famous story
as the river was on fire you know that
nope I missed it Cleveland to Cleveland
Ohio why is it so hot why is there not a
direct flight to Cleveland though so
that's because it's a major city that's
because a lot of these airlines
consolidated I guess and they they that
so the little the little companies that
used to compete with them or oil town
and steel one of the richest people in
the world that we're in Cleveland on one
point that's why the architecture is so
astounding god it's nice yeah it's
incredible you know what else I noticed
there wasn't there's no chain
restaurants
oh really didn't see one runs out weird
to slime in so it's known for its corn
beef best sounds ever in my life
they notes roots just leave looks so
nice yeah not a bad place left too cold
that's the thing I go I'm at could live
for and the guy goes you can't right now
you can't realize if you here a few
months it goes right because he gets
bitter cold here out that's right say no
more fam I'm out that's right that's why
I live in Pittsburgh great town in the
summer beautiful Philly - yeah yeah but
gets well too cold for us well too cold
for us we're like the very South you
have to live in the south yeah I like it
I like I like the south I like it to be
dank and kind of wet we also like I
don't like south south like New Orleans
Florida to do I like Miami but it's like
I don't know my body feels good not me
my skin gets all greasy I'm sweating my
hair gets curly yeah
looks like [ __ ] in the south yeah
dimepiece la [ __ ] in the south mmm you
know I'm saying yeah you need some dried
needy dry climate I'm surprised with all
your sports and all your years of
training you don't have aches and pains
in your joints when it's dry mm-hmm you
don't have pains it's very interesting
just in my heart just your heart but you
don't have you don't have knee have you
ever had a knee operation no after all
those years of football and you have
seen that one knee operation no bodies
rather sturdy sturdy I mean when I run
for
Miney act but your shoulder you two you
don't really have there's got to be some
kind of injury but not next a little on
the not the best but yeah I'm all right
for the most part you your horse come on
you horsey man John horse John horse
giant horse and and after that that is
something to be I don't know anybody
who's done sports that long it doesn't
have at least one in the operation or a
shoulder thing I don't know I don't know
one person and I bet if you rack your
brain you don't either I bet you can't
come over well not about it to find one
athlete that's never had an operation
one athlete that you know OJ Simpson
there's not true his knees are a
disaster an absolute disaster one out
one athlete please I'll wait you don't
know one athlete he's really weird after
how many years twenty years of football
long time playing football and on a high
level and then UFC not a shoulder not on
me not an ankle nothing
just own I was just a loose chin and
brain I was there for your [ __ ] neck
injury that still bothers me and that
was that was that was eight months of
[ __ ] for you cuz I'll turn your neck and
you still had to fight and then I want
to take down Travis brownie said cool
story let me sprawl on your neck to open
this fight out uh-oh I think I broke my
neck he goes did you well why don't we
try up get in your face too huge how's
that feel and now I'm gonna got sake and
I want it now I'm gonna punch you now
I'm gonna punch you while you're down
okay and then you can get $30,000 tough
life
tough love dude I [ __ ] back in the
day back in the day there's no such
thing as old times um how about I I
bowled with Derek and ass on in
Cleveland yeah well I didn't tell these
silly bucks what I didn't tell them yeah
is my daycare grown-up was bowling alley
Oh mister shop papa shop oh we played
excuse me
every Saturday Brian really every
Saturday night you got to go to
Brunswick lanes
you got some touch J Schwab and I you
got the ball you got touch I didn't tell
these silly [ __ ] that oh now here's the
thing
I mean Derrick grew up playing too
because well he open up I beat the
[ __ ] a both of them but the second
round
Derrick I think
should be on the Pro Tour he hasn't
played in forever he almost bought with
200 what I was what like I think I
averaged like 160 so he beat I haven't
bowled in years dude I bowled like a 160
average I hold like 167 140 so pretty
damn yeah not bad for not bowling very
very this [ __ ] guy balls like ass
that's him on the right he looks crazy I
feel absolutely homely this year's
atrocious economy he's the best he's a
comic he's hilarious
crushed Botham crushed but you're very
ethnic I love you Hassan is from
Pakistan originally I don't know don't
even know no don't know excuse me he's
from San Francisco Brian I understand
his ethnicity
Hassan is a Muslim name Muslim name he's
from India
oh he's in India sure he's not Pakistani
I'm positive so he's from India but any
of your numbers father's okay NASA
scientists yeah in the world of course
hey anytime Indian or Pakistani here
they're they're scientists or a doctor
or a lawyer dude so how about we have to
share the only knock on hilarities best
club top five for me all-time great that
place love Nick leathery will involved
green room awful green room yeah so
there was I remember this is a
transgender show going on
what'd he call me a burlesque show right
yeah but I was there with a kid Oh dick
sent it so is the Gay Pride yes either
yes so Wallace on Derek and I are
walking around we look like the most
gender you're you guys we went now you
got bicultural gays around so I'm
getting all these views I'm they're just
I bomb that morning it's like the United
Nations a [ __ ] for you guys yeah I look
just like a giant Cuban baseball player
yeah we're getting weird looks dude
anyways that was the back of that that
was the that was the greenroom
well this is good headdress on him looks
like it here the night we had to shoot
share the dress room with him he looks
like somebody put a glasses on a
flamingo like a giant chest here yeah
he's a bird hey there is nothing better
than when we come when we come into town
and he's on his tinder app looking for
girls
say how loud can you oh yeah what do you
mean it's gonna help him out he's single
dude it's great and he's swiping it's
great oh yeah me and Derek just go
through and tell him to swipe right or
swipe left it is so interesting a lot of
girls are in history in the indian guy
yeah yeah until he gets a little more a
little famous and they see how fun
that's what I told him
yeah I said you think Aziz is worried
about that bro
ah bro now she's got you a little more
famous mm-hmm
plenty of sorry plenty of young days be
all over that Indian dong Indian pipe we
looking forward that goes me into that
Indian chapati chapati you know which is
something that is super Indian I thought
these are Indian chapatis are basically
flatbread there yeah so ins give me all
over their land deck that Aladdin Cindy
all of your your Indian samosa what's
super Indian what's some Indian dude
there's such a bad thing I don't know
the Indian culture I'm embarrassed
I know Indian food very well it's
religious Oh
his dad I'm trying to tell them I'll
invest in a dude make a food truck you
and your dad uh-huh
is that well hold on the dad's a NASA
scientists they didn't give a [ __ ]
and I'll saw him a comic man what I know
but you do a food truck oh my his mom's
a millionaire - yeah highly eyed ramen
Family Dollar educated he's the
disappointment I think well he'll
probably be very successful he's funny
right so dude yeah funny
yeah funny funny one of these one of
these young dudes he's a killer funny
funny you will how about uh what
Saturday night I even between shows I
found out that Anthony Joshua lost from
your oh my god you did yeah I didn't
white house on stage you want to tell
you just go to social media right now
don't look up don't look at social media
don't worry if I just watch the fight
and I was like Oh Josh surpri knocked
around three seconds something I watched
it with Frank Grillo and Frank said
Frank said I said boy and he said yeah
they said it standing about Buster
Douglas a Mike Tyson he goes I'm telling
you this guy rotis has got he's
fundamentally flawless and I was like
shout out I wanna kill him fundamentally
flawless well yeah but he's just a bowl
he's so [ __ ] good well I also think
maybe Anthony Joshua isn't as good a
boxer as this guy and also I think he
overlooked a my things number things I
think Ruiz is toughest [ __ ] yeah he's a
very good boxer efficient got starched
and got back up tough man I mean he
might be doing the food-truck Diaries
with your boy next week really yep Wow
stay away I want you stay away from my
making friends I want to go train in his
gym learn how to box yeah you kids you
guys have similar styles similar yeah
yeah I would work for me right I could
but that's how I found out that he that
Joshua lost the fight via text right
wait oh [ __ ] I I think that Anthony
Joshua hey can I be honest did you fart
do smell awful no I swear to God really
it smells like [ __ ] I don't smell really
no oh I have a good sense of smell -
yeah you do me - we both you smell
something smells like fart dude really
yeah maybe the AC maybe you farted no
Stacey dude figured out I keep going he
I think Anthony Joshua is third place
out of fury
wild xxx great well and I don't think it
beats Ortiz again and I think oh you
don't think coupe authorities I don't
mean Ruiz Ivan Ruiz I don't think
Anthony Joshua in the Rema yes he's
Hannibal
I think he probably beats him he has
this it's a fight it's a fight fight how
does he he how does he beat I don't
think he's alright I don't think he was
in the right frame of mind going on that
fight I think you I think Ruiz is tough
as they come in yeah even Joseph Parker
had to you know yeah it would happen in
New Zealand but just parked as good as
they get he beat him by decision a lot
of people gave to Reese so um I think
it's a fight for sure but I think Joshua
can beat them but it's a much better
fight yeah but you're right Joshua is
third when it comes to he's not being in
series number one I would say so as well
because it's all about styles I would
see it no but I think that if Anthony
Joshua fights our boy Deontay Wilder or
not - I was gonna punch him that's right
I didn't go past the third - you really
that's what you think he starts
I agree with you it's just and it's not
knock down Johnson style matchups but I
think Joshua verse Furies a better fight
then Wilder verse Joshua cuz water would
start Jim yeah I think Fury and Joshua
be a [ __ ] think I I wonder if Anthony
Joshua and his team knew that from day
one and they that's why they were
correct yeah correct
III so everyone we were saying it
forever people you're just a homer it's
like minute I'm telling you another
thing I know personally how the
negotiations how Joshua water went but
see I would have said back I would have
said for all this I would have said
Joshua because he's big he's bigger than
Jonte and he's and my opinion I thought
he was a more fundamentally sound boxer
he's flood abilities and now our boy
Deonte welders throwing body shots he's
getting better as a boxer it's so crazy
how he came to jump they still not as
good as fundamental boxers Joshua talk
don't paint Josh from the negative light
just see last one like that now that he
was a huge favorite yeah Joshua is
Olympic gold medalist Klitschko Kishore
as far as fundamental after get he's
better than all those guys yet he's his
his his his boxing skills are better
than it's just his smile he looked like
he was boxing differently his weight was
over his front foot like he looked
different in this fight he just don't
think he gave a [ __ ] you're smiling
before the fight smile after he lost
yeah it's like yeah that was interesting
but no don't take don't don't
that's why I was telling everyone I'm
below the belt don't don't [ __ ] on
Joshua now he's a he's amazing fighter I
would say it seems that Ruiz has such
fundamentals I mean he seems like such a
like school well school he's an Olympian
yeah I didn't know that you know he had
105 amateur fights yeah yeah mystic I
was you know this is he belongs here he
belongs here
155 pound weight class from anybody in
the top ten in on any game day can yeah
from from 125 to tube AC 185 you can see
one through I'd say come through 20
killers in the right match of any night
can beat anyone that's right that's not
exactly right
and in box a heavyweight you know but
boxing usually you can predict right
can't you I mean usually boxing you can
be like well you know that you can tell
by the styles you can tell by just some
guy
just too good and and that's why the
odds are crazy you can be more accurate
with boxing I feel for sure
but in this case Wow I mean even like
surveillance going it's got a box he's
got a puncher's chance
most people say the only way I see this
winning is a lot of experts a lot of
truths who didn't know about any Ruiz
they did pry didn't see how any was
fights right but when I saw I was
against just Parker I was again this
gets [ __ ] tough yeah I am I mean I
still think Anthony Josh was third or
fourth in this hope in this whole group
I think Ruiz is probably here to stay I
think he gives everybody a fight how do
you think Ruiz does against Tiant a
walker
hmm can'tcan't different matchup tough
fight yeah cuz he does get hit the
difference train Wilder and Joshua so
Joshua's land on right set him down yeah
he sat him down
you don't unless you're Tyson Fury made
of what the gypsy magic me gypsy you
know they don't get up dude while it's
just a different animal so don't annoy
the thing that's alarming about if
Ruiz's to fight Deonte is John T's gonna
land and no one comes back after Deonte
lands nobody comes back after that no
one has wild I'm fury did he got up but
out by the grace of [ __ ] it's very
magic but other than that it is so weird
I already hits it's so weird it's so
scary him and Joshua as far as not got
parts not even close
really oh no wilder touch of death it's
so crazy he almost killed a guy Brazil
it was kill saw what yeah that guy was
so scared he went into this weird tough
man but um I guess Ruiz does get hit so
you can't afford to get hit anytime a
guy gets hit again swallow your oh
that's not good you can't get him you
gotta fight him like fury you just got
standing outside box him don't trade
yeah but that's not what Maurice closes
distant cuz it correct because with the
nightmare if your fight Walter that's
what he wants
well while is a disaster if you're on
the end of his punch if you're close I
wonder probably say anything
yeah you can't anybody who gets into a
slugfest close up toe-to-toe with Ruiz
is gonna have some trouble cuz good
Deontay Wilder will also get knocked out
by that guy because he's a lot smaller
he's a lot thinner so if he you can't
you nobody's gonna take those weird he
throws those over the
sort of like hooks that's weird almost
like he's hitting me with his elbow hmm
you don't want to be on the receiving
end you know what I'm on the shut up I'm
on the Rays shop you can suck
Deonte out you can go [ __ ] Sam I'm on
the ruie strain you know what you never
heard of the guy until Saturday night so
I don't get it we'll find out this is
hard yeah you know what all my chips are
on their ways I'm going with that guy
the whole Lou it man
I mean his ex fights Josh we can't find
anyone to else yeah gotta beat him again
it's in England kind of beat him
I think Joshua what Joshua said I'm
gonna make some changes does he go who's
camp he's surrounded by morons he is
yeah Eddie he earns more on his promoter
they just miss man Jim yeah really this
is a new ball so the picture that he
took inside the locker here's 27 corner
men what he done
why do you got such a big entourage of
course they didn't work out right so
he's gonna go find one person Thank You
moe retired - Wow so he's gonna find
he's gonna find you I'm gonna make
changes he's gonna pull you this corner
man different Randall you this what are
we doing oh my god oh my god a race for
McLaren or Ferrari cuz that's how many
they need that's crazy
those are all the people in his
entourage yes look how they all have
this shirt on the [ __ ] that's why would
you all fly over from England for this
that's where they worried although that
also tells me something else about his
mindset he needs a lot of people around
him I don't think it yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know him
personally yeah I know everyone speaks
volume am very smart yep very educated
very you know great boxer I think he's
mishandled management yeah I mean that's
crazy how many quarterman there are
there what are we doing nutritionist
trainer your boy will move on from
fighting after this but your boy cowboy
and Tony fridge gonna fight this weekend
this weekend you just fell and I hit
Indiana I'm gonna have to cancel my
Indiana shows do it dude what's wrong
with your ear nothing some I said just
pick at it that feels nice to play with
my lobe lobes are nice I don't see my
lobes connected straight tomato yet I
got some yes lobes like Jay my son's got
ears that are
where the Sun has trouble hit in his
face that be fun for him in school he
can find his way with that collocation
every super fun firm we get the middle
school yeah he's a bass made great time
he's a boy bad I was looking at zeros I
was like well dude I mean you must be
able to hear everything everything get
into being a spy cowboy verse 20 person
okay now I did know this by the way no
you didn't I did I know they did but I
like to be dramatically bomb not gonna
be able to shows in Indiana I didn't do
that helium this weekend Saturday you
see me in the end come see me in Indiana
now listen and he moves from tickets
yeah this is tough look I don't need I
need to move some ticks serve market
start your flavor
you know I'll fly all the way out there
gonna move some days I gotta move some
tickets hi I'm not sure what's going on
I go you know tickets aren't what they
usually I've been adding shows yeah
selling out hey you know you love your
bird not your market is lower birds
night market well I take it personally
oh who does they take it super
personally so so you let's go out let's
come out and do some stuff now um I who
you go I know who you have a despite you
do even put in 50 meet and greets you
meet the fans after do you have any fans
that talk to share about your friends
well not people like of course I [ __ ]
ditch that count I'm like yeah hey man
yes well that's like my best friends I
do and they whisper to you like dude hey
yeah and I'm like what what sorry man
I'm sorry
welcome unto me like dude you're funnier
than Julia I saw him you're funny
howling all right dude I guess so I
guess my friend man these two days a
couple look both ways and they came
listen we didn't want to say this and we
don't have a says but we saw Joe Rogan
and don't get me wrong he's amazing but
you're funnier yeah I was like all right
on that one day I don't know what that
means we don't we don't we don't compete
it's not how we look at this [ __ ]
ridiculous things very strange
Wow they just just it's also hilarious
though I know what were you say about
Donald ah I know I know seven tickets so
far seven no I do know I did the hottie
sold seven no that's not true
he's been doing comedy not for to you no
no it's not sure um come and come out or
I'll quit but um if I have to take it to
a cold things aren't great I'm not gonna
show up now listen um uh I know who you
have in this and I know who I have in
this and we don't I don't pick against
cowboy well secretly you might have
Ferguson cuz I got cowboy well anyway
just said on PDF cowboy would any secret
no no but good night this is a tough
matchup for cowboy 100% well it is but
on every aspect
see I think Cowboys wrestling matches
Tony Ferguson's and I'm terribly
grappling wise and I'm telling you it
does not it does not okay wrestling yeah
yeah yeah
jujitsu wise they're of comparison Shih
Tzu say it right you [ __ ] two eyes yeah
but start a straight wrestling no
because Tony has that College pedigree
and all that very high-level wrestling
yes yeah so you think I don't know how
much I don't think if you notice Tony
really doesn't [ __ ] with the wrestling
you against pedis users down for the
exchange and cowboys down for the
exchange so I really don't see a lot of
wrestling being had here you need a war
I think yeah I think it fight of the
Year status yeah I think it's gonna be a
bloody one Cowboys aren't such those
odds
he's on such a roll but he filed how
many weeks ago well yesterday that's
what I don't like three weeks ago four
weeks ago yeah but Alli Quinta that's a
while ago was that may well last month
just exactly a month that's not long ago
Brian and it was a decision yeah he has
been on a bit of a roll here submission
tkl decision mm-hmm oh dude you know who
was on my plane
shut up the cowboy you know who's on my
plane was Robin Thicke sat next to me on
my plane from LA yes yeah well he said
hi and introduced himself Dino had
glasses in and I was like what kind of
[ __ ] worship us on the plane first of
all dime piece how old is he 40 probably
no yes we - 42 - not not a bounce of
grey and very handsome glasses Dylan a
slice Criss Angel
yes sat down he goes how you doing Robin
all right man I know who you are dude so
talented yeah handsome dude when it's
after yourself a little talk sure didn't
cuz you meant exhausted on it yeah I
didn't sleep either I went yeah I'm
exhausted too and he goes this should
help pops a pill I'm so jealous
it was out before announcements for the
flight took off woke up as soon as it
landed Wow
and you were flying from Cleveland yeah
he was performing I don't know what he's
doing I didn't ask him he put on his
headphones pop that pill was out sees
his father I I worked where I wanted to
say that - I wanna say I'm sorry about
your dad he said I don't know him so I
didn't want it like his father was such
a great guy
Robin Alan Thicke Alan Thicke and a
really great guy like a couple of long
conversations with him and my sister and
her husband rented his house
everything's done on a handshake he was
a great guy and he was playing with his
hockey was playing hockey and he had a
heart incident and he looked at his guys
and he goes sorry
I'm an [ __ ] can't play sorry guys
can't finish the game I'm an [ __ ] why
can't everybody laughed when died okay
you won't know it's crazy and I don't
believe in this [ __ ] either yeah I saw
it months before he was on that Tyler
the medium show and he goes you need get
your heart checked out man three months
before goes telling you get your heart
checked out there's something wrong with
your heart
yeah however remember that his family
had a history of heart problems are just
saying though that's not weird
well they do a lot of research just
going to that kid does a lot of research
he has a people Latino researchers so
what happens is when you have all the
men in your family had heart issues so
I'm so wait he later said that that
stuff is pretty easy to track down the
same and you don't be supposedly and
this is what they're telling so he
doesn't know who he's seeing but till he
gets through the door oh that's that's
that's a course a lie okay I appreciate
that I appreciate you saying that okay
and I do they're all liars and so was
that kid that kids uh it's fine he's
made a good living well he's gonna read
your future luck y'all yeah and by the
way anybody who pays to get hit a
reading done should lose their money
it's good if you're a soccer and you're
that unscientific and I know that I'm
being closed-minded but good friend
listen I'm sure hey Stein home real
quick let's say he can to actually do it
though and that'd be crazy yeah what
sure what would be cool if pigs flew
there's lots of cut school stuff that
would happen but it could make some more
money than both of us bullshitting
though I'm sure well I'm just around all
over doing it
Tyler go suck your balls oh yeah
go read your future suck your balls yeah
and that's not the only thing that's
interesting about him tickets also live
you ain't get tickets that's what that's
what they make their money like you know
the Long Island medium lady she makes
more money than 99% of torn comics know
I sound like a huge theaters be like I
feel like someone's father died over
here raise your hand there we go so and
that's just like layin homeboys schedule
look how look Atlantis Atlantic City
sold out why is it casinos Auditorium
yeah good for him a lot of something
about the [ __ ] again what know what
what would his groupies be
older stud men older miss he's a twink
yeah yeah guys who are like 40 and studs
with money and they're manly they have
beards but like we call them groupies
what would you call his groupies um I'd
call them thugs thugs I'd call him bears
bears bears no that's the name that's
that's the name for us crying a guy
who's crying there is that it's just not
just right that's Helen Mirren no yeah
it is a younger actress that's Helen
Mirren bro no I don't think that's Helen
what's that girl's name I know who she
is she's she kind of wet sort of not
crazy bit a little off her on handle no
she's married to a girl Oh dated a girl
oh and yes yeah I've never heard of her
so I don't care what else you got Jen
who cares
never heard of her she started of all
the ones a stop on you know she did the
Kardashians and how dare you Tyler how
the how dare you not bring up Rob
Kardashian and how dare you Nicole
Simpson and [ __ ] I love all this
[ __ ] it's great listen it's fun let
him make his money if your son started
doing this you would say [ __ ] no I mean
you know if he wants to be a liar it's
fun but it's a good kind of lie because
he's its entertainment he's an energy
[ __ ] is entertaining yeah he's no I'm
just saying what if in some far-fetched
world he actually can talk to the yeah
yeah well what if I mean be amazing
boyfriend I feel lucky to call this
extra team in my valence I thought it's
the same person it looks exactly yeah
there's us yeah oh it's kind of two
Twinkies though I can't see myself
it's too sweet this is that's a high
fits a tech of height extra bacon -
actually the guy looks exactly like me
there is no jack yourself off accounts
like your own dick hold it
he's 17 now I don't he's young he's
probably 48
really good for him listen man he fell
how many people claim they can do this
he's like the main one
you think it stopped everywhere he goes
would it be exhausting cuz everywhere he
goes he like reads mine yeah we're like
the dead talk don't be exhausting to do
if it was real keep coming up with
reasons that's like that's like that
awful [ __ ] horrible woman what's her
last name
Oh Sylvia brown a real horrorshow and
she goes I see I see it says she's on
Montel Williams the Montel Williams gave
her a platform this [ __ ] liar
and she already was in trouble for fraud
she got in trouble what does she do be
where you going with Virginia and so she
goes to the loo she a mind reader yeah
she goes I see her husband died in in
water I saw him on [ __ ] woman goes in
died in 9/11 hmm she goes to the tower
who was there water and she goes well
maybe the sprinklers were on I don't
know she wasn't look at her she was I
she was a real and I can believe her I'm
believed the young twink though yeah she
was a horror show you know my gosh she
was a bad person what you really a bad
person did she die she was caught saying
I got tape saying you know dumb people
deserve to be duped and all that she was
a real did you see that that pastor I
think Segura
Tom Segura post on his Twitter that
Pastor where that interview goes hey
you've been known to steal millions from
the people and you're buying private
jets how do you feel about that and he's
not really ready to answer have you seen
this no oh my dad did this no he's not
to interview it he he posted or
retweeted let me see
and it's I found it fascinating man keep
going when you look at these do go to
tweets and replies are just the front
page just his regular page I think man
okay I don't know I use Twitter kept
goin didn't keep going keep going isn't
in May 29th what I don't know what they
were and it was a it's a pastor I'm
pretty sure it was him
[Music]
damn I don't know where we gonna be able
to find it now
[ __ ] but it's it's this it's like one of
those black gospel guys who's known for
stealing I wonder if he can type it in
put put um Tom Segura pastor no no no no
God no put God I don't we can put go
what would you call a preacher preacher
gets questioned by journalists or
something like that
someone help me out here who knows how
to use the internet Peter gets
questioned that should reach you get
stomped by journalists so that's so that
Kenneth Copeland all right keep going
down not this one it's gotta be this
right play it's so funny and he you can
see it's frustrating don't you oh this
is it what's going on what the [ __ ] is
happening why you're sad that you won't
fly commercial you said that it's like
getting into a tube with a bunch of
demons not the people the main reason is
because of the need if if I flew
commercial I'd have to stop 65% of what
I'm doing that's really isn't it true
that you want to fly commercial so that
you can fly in luxury how much money did
you pay for Tyler Perry's Gulfstream jet
for example well for example that's
really none of your business but you
trust us yes of your donor Edison I hate
you can't have caught me off guard here
okay oh sure I'd like to give you a
chance to to catch your breath and and
have a conversation we don't want to we
don't want to catch off-guard love
Inside Edition you gotta get this now
hey you listen to me my wife is inside
this
oh yeah Wow thank you lord so let me
pray a second question a lot of people
think it's unbecoming for a creature to
live a life of luxury and to fly around
in private jets what's your response to
that very simple it takes a lot of money
to do what we do we have brought over a
hundred let's see this the latest
figures just came out he's on there one
hundred and twenty-two million people to
the Lord Jesus Christ let me give you
another example how crazy it's had a lot
of work as you get the Bryan Callen
surgery or doing a future right now as a
long ways I had a week off and I was
scheduled for Peru and I prayed about it
and I thought I'm not missing that
dedication in Jerusalem there's a crazy
without the airplane that we have that I
bought from Tyler Perry and I didn't pay
any more any Tyler's one of the greatest
yeah he made it he made that airplane so
cheap for me I couldn't help but buy it
okay all right my hands are very kids
it's he not singing
he seems like there's a demonic outfit
watch your twit twit and switches on her
watch here's what happened oh go don't
say that we flew in 21 days 17 hours
40,000 miles
touched five continents and preached
face-to-face personally with a hundred
and twenty five thousand people do you
ever just keep trolling use your private
jets to go visit your vacation homes for
example okay again getting back to the
comment you said that you don't like to
check commercial because you don't want
to get into a tube with a bunch of
demons
let me believe that human being I feel
them though I do not and don't look ever
say I did watch freak I've scared that
we wrestle not with flesh and blood look
at his hand principalities and powers
see essentially what you meant he's an
evil man is how evil does he feel he's
simple you said you didn't want to get
into a tube with a bunch of demons did
you mean - no - with a bunch of demons
that spirit airline slogan we think that
people that fly commercial or demons
give me a chance to talk sweet heart
I'll explain this - but it's a biblical
thing it's a spiritual thing it doesn't
have anything to do with people people
God's love people Jesus I'm so but then
it's pretty much get pushed in alcohol
do you think that's a good place for a
preacher to beat and prepare to go
preach to a lot of people when somebody
in there is dragging some woman down an
aisle that made me so mad to see that on
television I wanted to punch the guy out
myself I can't be doing that while I'm
getting ready to preach you just don't
like to be around the sinful people or
the the hurtful people is that what
you're saying I'm gonna say
his hands are the scariest part back
during the days that we couldn't do
anything else we had a travel commercial
I when I went to Oral Roberts University
I flew for Oral Roberts I'm worship out
so I spent a lot of time in error you
have how many planes we get like simply
and we still have our citations you and
then we have a little small airplane but
both those are the two ones that we use
and we use them all the time and other
people use them too we have other
ministries that that usually in the book
of Ephesians against ah bitchin oh
that's nice is that night awful they're
great whoa Kenneth Copeland I can't be
Flyman with demons in a tube Wow
she was great good for her what a bad
guy dude how creep
that guy who well when you're lying all
the time when your life is a lie he
reminds me of the judge from The
Hunchback of Notre Dom well he's just a
horror show man he's so scary he is he
does what nightmares me his best child
or his that's a really bad guy no he
looks like Satan bro
that's what the devil to me is the eyes
it's all in the eyes in a very dangerous
dangerous person and people quite
responsible for a few bodies I would
guarantee he does anything he can get
away with that's a sociopath we get his
dick beaters look at this finger that's
it that's a sociopath that's a guy who
gets away with you know he's a false
prophet that's what it is jesus warned
about that anyway his own the person he
prays to God see a guy and living living
like a king oh my god donation spread
the word of God it's the oldest scam in
the [ __ ] world so yeah the area of
the oversold is thrown over worst what a
piece of wealthy what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah bad guy but you know it and I'm
amazing people never but people are
desperate and they're looking it's not
about Christianity those guys are just
they're just they're just money hogs
those guys who do it could be that was
just their hustle yes they just used
that as Jesus to hustle yeah but if
there was no money in it they want to be
Christian it's the same thing is like
for some some pedophiles saying how can
I have sex with kids oh I know
I'll go become a priest and nobody's
watching it has nothing to get to the
kid that's right the easiest happening
for them to make money is through the
cows right that's a bit kind whatever
that's right there you'd be Muslim if
they went hey it wasn't me give you 200
more million all right [ __ ] am Islam
he'd kill people he'd do whatever that
whatever it takes the day they're there
about themselves that's in that scary so
he gets to tour and be there be a rock
star basically and you know Wow
it's been doing it forever as me mm-hmm
he's got so much I wonder how many
followers he's got whoo look here I
didn't have an Instagram does the hell
list I think he does what's his name
Kenneth Copeland I would imagine he does
but it's just like just like scripture
went to Oral Roberts University - yeah
223 well obviously his father's aren't
on there yeah someone runs it would it
be dope if you went to and it looked
like [ __ ] Gucci's Instagram like just
him with like and let me know God and
first she what if he had shoes like me
today that'd be sick he does he just
can't post about it can't flex on the
gram dude I bet you he has some I bet he
calls some angels I bet just says oh
that's how I thought about Oh
dude how many girls is yeah look at know
I seen this guy know easy it is for him
to talk her than to suck in his gospel
ha ha you have to that's the Lord's work
so if you want to get a house what a
great hustle though scary dude he looks
so evil to me so he had his own he had
his eyes done you see that that's for
real he had his lids done that's why you
have to be very careful with how you do
your on chop them off yeah they tighten
the lid so you see how my lids are going
down like this what we do you can bring
them back up but that's that's that
doesn't when your son he looks on you
gotta be careful do it be I'm gonna get
a little look little nip tuck ready uh
oh wow
I'm Ryan 20 years ago dude I'm gonna
look really good you should do it yeah I
want to have your lids you're coming in
with me what is nice cart is your mind
starting to fall down a mine still good
now you're good I did want to get the
dares but it is funny how you looked
younger when I first met you things
changes in eight years we're nice well
he looks absolutely evil he is I would
say he is not a good guy I can't make
someone a piss I get to get pee let's go
let's go piss hard current let's do some
current events what do you think okay
Brian let's go to me alrighty first one
so much a fan sent this in it's a clip
from America's Got Talent where the
contestant is a autistic man
this shows uh in oh yeah
Gabrielle Union not mad at her sir I
have trouble watching this stuff and I
don't know what trouble watch because
it's it's so hard to who give who do
what 10,000 bucks gave it dislikes is
that his mom he's blind is he blind
he's also blind know the biggest thing
is gonna take a while to get that PA but
by the time he gets to the let me see
what he says here or they ask him what
he has that's his mom please be good 24
million views he better be [ __ ] good
Simon looks several Kentucky six
spending money and [ __ ] chicks yeah
that's what's up where were you in San
Simon don't hate on Simon huh that's my
boy off yeah little personality huh hope
Terry Crews okay a world yeah I [ __ ]
love this show
and I don't watch it have you ever seen
it no I like when they're able to
perform
yeah but hope you start crying so I was
here damn the llamas get them hyped up I
always feel bad the parents are white
get me being a parent myself that's what
gets me is he helps a blind he's legally
blind whoa what the [ __ ] that's crazy
that's crazy
[Music]
is he on no chin yeah he's a mate money
money money
not a beautiful song oh and it crazy
like one area develops more than the
others and you got like that's a
priceless town yeah look at this [ __ ]
oh my god how does he do that if that
doesn't make you believe it lays it in
God do you understand I'm Sam I'm more
amazed you haven't seen any clips of
this over the last four days
I haven't that's the first time yeah
yeah I saw it it happened last week
right a couple days ago yeah yeah and he
ended up getting the golden buzzer from
Gabrielle which means they go straight
to the lie like that
that's it is trying to get to the live
results so that's so play it keep
playing when they so Brian no Sundance
that's crazy
dammit now that you hit through the
Brian McKnight so he can't see right now
he's a legally blind so prior LIBOR you
know how some people can kind of see
legally blind well he has a walking
stick with him he's blind he's as blind
as it gets they don't specify though he
can't see dude who is she
Julianne Hough she used to be on Dancing
with the Stars and then became a actress
I like her he's so he was so rough he's
drinking a lot he's delivering life man
I love his mom dude I could I can't
imagine dude I can't either
you remember when the the big kind of
ugly ladies saying yeah Susan Boyle I
mean it's pretty she's Kourtney's
Gabrielle Union she's yeah 50 I think -
she's like late 40s she's having does he
know what they're gonna do
can he so it's like the homerun do they
can manipulate you but no this is real
bra yes it's an image right that's reals
your jerky man they're really good at
doing that [ __ ] slow motion music
change but if that's not worth like
sometimes things are so small see they
deserve to be small t if you can't be
smoked over that that guy can [ __ ]
sing that's amazing man holy [ __ ] that's
so cool
that poor guy though that's so cool
I can't imagine that family man dude
dude there's nothing that not that this
has anything to do with this but when
you're having a kid you know when you do
did you guys do that when you you you
get results back to see there's any
deficiencies like Down syndrome and
other stuff dude until those results
come in it's scary yeah you gotta make
some serious decisions with that the kid
oh man if he is did you do yeah you do
man but to see that when they had that
gift Elton John's mother said she he
started he was like five I started just
playing at her she went oh I'm gonna be
rich
holy [ __ ] like he was just what's kind
of disappointing yeah mom what I'll make
[ __ ] money off this kid well no in
other words she said something like he
was a terrible story medias though that
as a kid though she was like I'm gonna
make me money yes well I'm in other
words in other words she goes she said
something in fact he was such a talent
right away and she was like I'm I'm this
kid's gonna be a superstar and I'm gonna
have a house yeah this heartfelt moment
you know it's crazy
Elmont John saw him I guess when you're
like buddy up when your child has a
talent like that you're you don't expect
it that's all set yeah I mean and then
you figure like if I had a kid like that
I would say we're going on tour right
now well your mama's gonna be a manager
you're gonna make me money and I'm
leaving here a 10% and you're not gonna
get any money I'm gonna feed you you're
gonna be my goose that lays the golden
eggs
juice alive but you gotta work for him
here's the thing
how about Macaulay Culkin's family did
that now it's a rule so like Tigers done
some bad stuff and uh you know Papa
can't touch that money I always give
them [ __ ] like you're about twenty eight
months late on rent and I hate to be a
stickler but I'm gonna need some sort of
cash gonna go pop up I'll have any money
I mean my I know this why this is a
tough conversation to have with you
because you're really back on rat man
and we got to figure it out
where's your money go pup I don't have I
should film this he goes Paul I don't
have any money I go again I hear what
you're saying I hate to come to you like
this but again it's your third birthday
and still paid a fret it's so funny he's
so serious he's so he's been in ads it's
like when he was a baby join I did some
stuff for them and he you know you got
paid good money yeah that guy Papa can't
touch that money it goes in my account
for him that's the Macaulay Culkin role
you know that no yo yeah I can't touch
it and then when he turns 18 because I
tried buying a bunch of shoes with this
money and so when he turns 18 I think
it's all that money it's awesome yeah
because Macaulay Culkin's pants [ __ ]
him over I let go for home alone you
ain't got 40 bucks sorry little dude so
now he doesn't have money I don't know I
think he's doing all right
you know he's on Rogue in a while ago
what is he doing I don't know I guess ya
just launched his own podcast so like a
year ago
he's on Rogan but I don't know but that
that rule did happen in entertainment
the Macaulay Culkin rule so they have to
have their own separate bank account the
pants can only touch like 10 or 20% of
it I don't know but I was only able to
buy two pairs of shoes with my son's
money yeah I don't know what he's doing
hell of a talent man he was so talented
as a kid oh dude you remember him and uh
not when he's a kid I bet you keep going
down I'm sure he can still act as a saw
no he's over it yeah Rogan talked about
it that Jim Gaffigan show for a while to
change
yeah Robot Chicken but he the one where
I was like whole party monster dad he
was getting party monster hmm he swears
to that Michael Jackson do not touch his
Willie I believe it I do not but that's
another day Wow it's a great kind of
zone oh good and Jacob's Ladder
that's an incredible movie dude Uncle
Buck
that's a great movie yeah shout out to
Uncle Buck what else we got chin chin
did you not see that tape tilt today or
did you see it over the weekend I saw it
every one human being can everywhere
I can't believe never saw it you stay
off social media yeah I I stay I don't
do any kind I don't really calms thing
like that but I go on like the general
page and I see like like that was
trending like that I don't know why I
didn't see it though because I do go on
Instagram when I'm crazy looking at like
chicks with dicks and stuff without do
you thought you'd miss that chicks and
eggs
cross cross yeah you're not gonna see
useless [ __ ] that I look at me I like
how all the top CrossFitters say they
don't do steroids it's my favorite thing
what else you got so yesterday a massive
cruise ship actually malfunctioned and
they had engine failure there were two
smaller tugboats trying to lead them to
a way away from the port but they ended
up crashing into the port and here is a
video song alright yeah
those people aren't running that I know
so I thought - they're not that skin so
I'm not going that fast and also yeah
but they could good run right over that
road all right so you know they're
they're trying to outlaw these big boats
in Italy in Venice they don't want on
that they're saying they're ruining the
city they're blocking views the
pollution they're not made like the
canals and everything's not made for
these giant things to be closed like
this you so they're trying to ban them
all so [ __ ] who ships what are we doing
cruise ships are so weird to me man
you're just like in a city on the ocean
it's a yeah it's all day what if me to
go to hotel yeah I've done it they're so
lame it sits at if you go with a group
it can be actually fun but I'm not for
me also
alright the guy feelings awfully not too
scared cuz he's just like there I think
it looks like it's stopped already
no it's moving definitely scary though
yeah the guy driving the boats like ah
[ __ ] hey malfunction
yeah probably what I think happened was
the engine failure and then I can't go
just kept going yeah just just kept yeah
they got [ __ ] big those things are
man it's a giant hotel it's a building
on a floating bill yeah it's crazy see
how much how much I mean it five ways
what would you say you know I'm gonna
say a million I'd say two million pounds
I might be too much 220,000 gross tons I
don't know what that mean I know what is
know I know I don't care wait so that so
that would be so that would be five
hundred thousand that'd be five hundred
and forty thousand pounds
she said I'm sorry wait wait more than
glad that times mm I'm sorry that that
would be five million times right what
would that be Oh Celie you don't [ __ ]
about 44 million pounds five hundred
thousand belts two hundred you know
about five hundred
I should have known this 2200 tons is
2,000 pounds per ton so you have to do
that mm mm to 44 million Yeah right
million I can't I get lost 140 million
it is not 140 million at six zeros isn't
it I can for hire 40 million I think no
four counts that's four million to three
one two three now it's 44 million 44
million guys 40 formula would be 4
million pounds no and Brian thought a
cruise ship weighed 500,000 pounds I
said no no yeah you did well that's easy
I said I say a million tons that's
turning 20 so what is that 440 million
no yeah how many zeroes is that seven
zeroes oh I get lost in the zeros 40
million pounds
holy [ __ ] if I can heavy dude yeah hey
after you like heavier like an elephant
well here's think I don't care they're
happy like buildings dirt you what why
it's crazy that's just a car something a
human can live it's like cheese brownie
she's me that building ways I've no clue
man I don't care after saving who cares
they're so heavy
they're just years a certain number if
there's like over a thousand pounds a
building over a thousand pass after a
hundred thousand pounds like do you
think 100 five hundred thousand pounds I
have no clue yeah well that's like I was
talking to [ __ ] uh I was with Doug
Davidoff and he and I could give a [ __ ]
and I'm with Gavin and some of my
filmmaker friends and they're talking
about the best lighting I've ever worked
with and why
Oh get off [ __ ] up hot biscuits with the
way to sleep I am I know it's important
to wait room talking about 45 pounds or
a fast car super specific with dates I
am May in mate 2009 may 5th 2009 is the
last time I actually I have a friend
does hey man can you do my show July
27th oh wait if I'm alive I responded
back how dare you
here's why I don't know what I'm doing
next week dude yeah I can't do that just
can you do it
I've no I go do you want to be honest
have no idea could not tell you dude my
family does that to me
so next Christmas are you oh god don't
shut down while I do I shut down I'm
already I take a nap he asked my
question I said they have to take a nap
exhaust me my dad goes over you know
this car show and all you say August huh
yeah yeah no I guess I'm gonna just book
you know I don't know amount man I'll
tell you the week off will say I'll see
oh god I should act with me week of
bring up weights again around me like
this I'm gonna punch you in the [ __ ]
face god that frustrate me how much is
that boat you think it's a giant cruise
ship Ryan weighs a ton that's all I want
exactly a ton or just ride over I didn't
no idea did it because I won when I was
9 or 10 in summer camp they asked us to
guess how much a rock weight it was a
giant rock and I somehow guessed by the
look of the drone in the area and I won
some [ __ ] butt bag of gumballs or
some [ __ ] I mean ever since then in my
mind I swear to god you're gonna thing
in my mind and I've always thought I'm
good at guessing I wait for you dude
good for you like it gave me confidence
of mine I love that I'm pretty good at
guessing weight well what you want to
know and then good yeah I'm a [ __ ]
I'm really step the marbles bike you
ever can guess how many marbles in here
gets a free haul path like I have no
idea no [ __ ] coke a lot how's that a
lot
well they do this called Fermi's with it
what they do now is they teach you so
you're supposed to do this you're
supposed to have know how to think about
things like this so if I say
how many piano tuners in New York City
there's a way to come to an answer so
even if you don't study anything like
that if I say how many piano tuners in
New York City dealt a lot of times in
certain like chemistry class the last
chemists they don't know they'll ask you
know people in literature guys and the
idea is that there's a way to think
about any problem you come across and
come to a reasonable answer so that a
good example is what do you mean piano
tuners I don't play piano and well it's
cool yeah what state no hold on before
you do that though what state your boat
yeah put your phone down
oh there's 37 do you want to address or
no because you know what age do you want
42 oh hey what do you want to do now
there's a way to do it because you can
you can extract much better ways
problems you have yeah but now with the
cell phone in that like a lot of schools
are teaching different like you know
kids don't remember back in the day you
have to remember date dates right that's
more [ __ ] anymore right but the way
but but say there are problems where you
you have to make reasonable guesses on
the fly and your phone can't help you so
like what well so so how many piano
tuners you can extrapolate this for I
know but give me something I can't
[ __ ] decisions and stuff right so you
say well how many pianos how many people
how many people actually have a piano
how many people play that piano how
often do people need a tune is once over
year how many actually do it it there's
a way to come down to like the answer is
1500 or you know maybe that's do you
have no clue what the end well there's a
way to do it where you actually get very
close to the answer
hmm all you have to do is know what the
population is and you can extrapolate
any answers remember the population one
piece of data can lead you to a very
reasonable guess that's all so you still
know what yeah yeah can I help you out
oh yeah
you took that thing guessing elementary
way too serious yeah not your thing
though nobody you know not your thing
but in science in science they unlocked
a lot of the mysteries of the universe
by watching things I'm sure electricity
they watched how water flow for sure you
know what's crazy is uh that who was it
the one that candidates the Democratic
the african-american girl actually like
how Maharis
did you see her on stage that guy ran to
the stage and jacked her mic and there's
no security what how did they not have
something
her husband or something but no he came
to her defense right the husband like
after form three minutes and she liked
Acula but they were I was watching a fat
cow right and they're saying that all
these candidates they don't have Secret
Service or most of them don't have now
so you should have how crazy is that's
crazy
especially in this current climate how
do you not you you up you're going all
over the world and how about the badass
in the middle she's the only one was
like hold up what the [ __ ] are you doing
everybody else freezes there's no
security watch this alright dangerous
now look at it look at this well if he
had a gun boom came over Letus no
security the girl in the middle is a
gangster I find her very attractive look
Eve a lady with a headset on nothing
look at the dumb ass in like black
khakis nothing look doing nothing this
guy is that her husband right that's her
husband in the suit that took two
minutes to get to the stage pick him up
and slam one's [ __ ] head in that
crazy though and they're saying that the
the government doesn't provide
candidates like Secret Service and then
they said well they can hire their own
security a venue should have security a
venue like that should have two big guys
like let us out but if I'm her right and
you have that funding why would you hire
legit secured may not have as much money
as you think I was she's doing pretty
good right enough for security mmm she's
pretty successful woman but you wouldn't
you do a tour when you're traveling
constantly you have to bring that person
with you everywhere you go or you can go
state to state you have to do that yeah
like a commie how crazy is this TV the
husband was far away and that's why I
took him so long her husband's got some
legs on he does I don't know I was like
yeah he came up the wait everyone's way
too calm for me okay but they're saying
that government doesn't provide that
Secret Service security for you have to
fire I could have got very bad that
could have been really you're right I
mean he's that crazy and I mean greatly
thank God it didn't happen no matter
what you think but any crazy there
hasn't been a fascination attempt on
Trump how many people hate wow they lock
that sure they've spoil Ike they've you
know foiled a bunch of plans but I can't
believe no one's gotten close a lot of
the people
against Trump I would argue don't own
guns and our our pro-gun control so a
lot of people that are for Trump are
probably owned guns do you don't say
anything you think everyone who's for
truck you know what I'm just saying for
the minority in here to think that one
yeah like nothing yeah they've got one
kind of scare when he was on campaign if
you remember that guy and they got a
monthly yeah but think about a lot of
the people who are against Trump tend to
be the intelligencia academics the media
educated college kids Hollywood that
know these people did a lot of people
who are it's not a lot of America's you
hunt and go hate it he said but he say
be globally - yeah like he's coming to
England that the front of the papers
like basically making fun of them he's
hated New York and are secretly secretly
Europeans are cheering his China policy
they love that he's sticking it to China
China is just basically unfair China
needs to be taken to task for the way
they treat their their dissidents I just
find it crazy that not I mean as much
hate this Trump gets no one's trying
assassination attempt now I'm sure
there's been some we just don't hear
about it there's secret services pretty
locked on yeah they don't [ __ ] i watch
the whole special in the Secret Service
in the president it's insane we I do
every time he moves all men millions of
dollar millions and they fly in months
ahead correct they they scout all the
locations they shut down certain hotels
yeah we'll have angles it's insane what
they do yeah and though the whole thing
that travels with him is insane but for
these other representatives I couldn't
believe that right yeah you're right I
just thought they'd have more like they
lose an axe you really like him - who's
the gay candidate oh I'm about a [ __ ]
but but no what's his first name
what a [ __ ] not but a [ __ ] yeah no
it's not in there like Canada Joey or
some [ __ ] like that
no I'm Joey butter no it's B you D Pete
oh look bye Pete but okay it's not
ignite but I get Pete bunny [ __ ] but so
so his name is actually P but his name's
Pete so it all slogans like vote for
Pete right real simple but him being the
first the kind of gay man - yeah for
president with a boyfriend husband
they'd like loud and proud don't give a
[ __ ] but he's all over he's on The
Breakfast Club he's on TMZ people love
him right well yeah they love them
yeah I'm surprised you know eventually
no just cuz America they're not ready
for that America is not gonna we are if
you put him up against Donald Trump
yeah you will good luck yes steamroll
he'll get steamrolled he's he's a little
guy who's gay America is gonna be like
what do you talk about dude though it
doesn't matter no I'm just saying yeah
yeah but like if Obama was gay I'd vote
for him I don't give a [ __ ] if they're
gay but that's I don't give a [ __ ]
that's you I don't care you would care
if you're president gay now I give a
[ __ ] I want a good I want a guy who
knows how to do the job but yeah I don't
care about your sexual orientation I
don't know I don't think he'd betray
Anthony well it doesn't matter why you'd
be smart that's what this job is stable
I don't care and I want you smart and I
want you off social media I don't want
you be controlled on social media
economies there's a person I like him I
don't know all his agenda and stuff like
that but as a person he's if the economy
continues to do this well it's gonna be
very hard to be Trump and he is and and
you just need to legit Canada it's very
the policies to try to have a lot of
support overseas with the Europeans and
stuff so we'll see to me it doesn't look
like Trump wants to be president again
he's probably dear God not another for
yeah I think his ego he's like let's
definitely win another four but I bet
deep down inside he's like god I don't
want to do this [ __ ] I don't know I've
better house it's probably not stick
it's much beautiful I think they say
he's exhausted from exhausted lastly
fighting it I always liked it with sinks
there he likes to be like - though and
he doesn't like that he's hated it was
celebrity welcome to the White House no
no one wants to [ __ ] with him it's crazy
yeah you know he's close with Hugh
Jackman do you know that no and Hugh
Jackman even really does you know like
they're very close and it was at one of
the they're airing it on Howard Stern
Howard was interviewing Hugh Jackman and
he's you're close with trauma
right but and you stick by him and hugh
jackman goes I mean listen man when me
and him were close he's always been a
really loyal friend he was at precedent
so just comes president I don't agree
with everything he stands for but yeah
remember he's my friend before he's the
president so I'm a loyal guy buddy
brands I don't agree with everything
that he does but he's my friend I'm not
gonna not be his friend because he's the
president States now my buddy who Brad
who is on the apprentice in 2005 has
stayed and stayed friends with Trump
this whole time like like and loves him
[ __ ] things he goes dude cool story
say what you will being around him he's
hilarious and he's a bro you know a lot
of guys are gay but they say with uh
yeah with hugh jackman others rumors
they's gay he did that play we're in on
Broadway
yeah so he did play on Broadway which
comes out in like sequence has like a
deep v cut net yeah and this is so funny
so in the play he kisses another dude
and he's gonna kiss this guy and some
guy in the crowd goes don't do it
Wolverine haha dead serious
like no god no the guy didn't know he's
a big Wolverine from don't do it
Wolverine and Hugh Jackson said he's
always tried to stay in character and he
was laughing so hard he was shake really
and he had to address it say just turn
around started laughing to the ground
his his his wife is way older that's his
wife I had some experience that's not
his wife I had some yeah I had something
way older I know I had some experience
with this I met him well he married
Sabretooth I'm fantastic
I met him please don't I met him very
very nice man and so town but but he was
doing a show in New York and when he
came in we watched the Tyson fight
together I think it was the Tyson fight
in fact you know what you know what it
was when Tyson bit Evander Holyfield's
ear that's when I think that's when I
think we watched it dude that's his wife
yeah yeah they're gonna get like 25
years
his wife is much older yeah there's a
there's a yeah they just you know they
have kids and they've just been gathered
for a long time yeah they look I mean
I'm I when he walked in the room he was
with beautiful three beautiful
men who were very gay but I think they
were in his show at the time he was
doing a Broadway show he was doing dis
singing and dancing hmm so you know yeah
so I just never been taken aback by the
fact that he was with these insanely gay
men and he was hanging out with them and
I was like that's interesting I just
thought it was interesting that mean
he's gay
no but it means he's gay that's all time
do I have that outfit yes well you're
gay too but I don't care let's put it
this way if I found that it was I don't
care and I wouldn't be surprised but who
cares
oh I all I know is I I know people that
know him really well and they say he's a
great dude in every way he's just a
[ __ ] good person yeah Howard ask him
out how we're asking about being gay and
he's like I just laugh it off if he
probably isn't he probably is boy you
just went on a 30-minute rant he hangs
out with gay men all the time
he does he does musicals and that's his
board that's not real this that's fake
yeah yeah looks at his son there could
be a son but habla de los Romero's no
that's really good though how does a
really just odd though he's so talented
as far as someone who can do it all Oh
dance
so everything's the real deal play whoa
hey man they keep him hold hands
that's himself I think okay he's
Wolverine yeah he said he stopped doing
you know he doesn't do well Vereen you
morning said he talked to Jerry Seinfeld
nice to help them get over do him over
he's like I'll never do it again he's
built like a break he was when he did
Wolverine just he's great as Wolverine
man he really is she got jacked guess he
called the rock for a workout tips so
you know what the rock told him shoot
yourself here's my guy and works at
Gold's Gym here's my doctor here's my
doctor care family background inject
yourself with testosterone in the dick
hole that's right and you know what if
they ask me be Wolverine I'll do the
same thing I need to I can't get over
his wife though yeah he's got a beard
situation I'm not timeout is Wolverine
chops there have been there have been
relationships but I you know I know a
gay man who dated women for many years
and had sex with them and was attracted
to them and who knows it's an
interesting situation might be is just
his best friend you know that's right
like in this exact trail the men aged
better than women and they're just
really close and feel like we're making
a lot of excuses for him but we'll fight
it I mean III come on man think of the I
think almost I think at the most he's
he's gay [ __ ] and at the very least at
the very least he [ __ ] guys a lot I'm
saying other than that I think he's
happily done to the head does he bustin
boys asses well let's not get too
details but I think that he's you know
you never know you never know you you
never know we do know he's gay well we
other than that we don't know anything
else and that's fine but talented
talented genius the live with Wolverine
everybody wins that's all it is
I was boy oh boy did a TR for the Joker
I'm looking at him with a shirt off and
well I'm I have a nice body
I'm sorry how you doing ADR relate to
what I was just looking at them and
maybe my shirts off in one scene oh and
the Joker yeah who knows uh who these
guys he's always with this person I
don't know his trainer
it's his trainer that's his trainable
wises trainer wearing up exactly I don't
know yeah well if I play like that I
wear that - I would - I'd look like this
yeah yeah oh they're in Santa Monica
they're at Santa Monica they just had a
good swim he's got a boner so you know
if you [ __ ] see water it's not
considered cheating it's a bunch of
picture seven well he I'm ready to be
Wolverine so you're me get you pretty
close
[Music]
well that's the one though they're
holding hands
so that's his trainer I don't know if
that's that looks kind of Photoshop well
they might just be bumping into each
other yeah yeah I bump into you all the
time
all right what else we got let's leave
you alone all right
so Pete Davidson just walked as a model
at a New York Fashion Show for Alexander
Wang he's officially a model straight
model huh mm-hmm that guy gets so much
hate here he does ah why God I don't I
guess pray cause he's [ __ ] ariana
grande for a while I guess he's skinny
enough for a model why did he do that we
don't know why he did it but he was
asked to come and model for Alexander
Wang's newest collection and he said
okay a lot of tats huh
yeah he's tatted up but I don't get why
people why so many people him but also
why people care all right so he's in New
York and I care you want to walk this
[ __ ] thing for Alexander Wang which
is a huge brand as I can't [ __ ] I'll
do it
yeah who cares is he tall yes I'll talk
uh six to at least looks fairly athletic
was he a ballplayer they play basketball
or anything I don't think so oops six
one I think hearing Kate Beckinsale no
longer together guys hate to break it to
you all right what else we got so a
principal of a Catholic school located
in Louisiana was on a field trip with a
bunch of middle school students they
went to take a trip to Washington DC and
he was arrested at a strip club because
he was intoxicated and refused to pay
his bill he had to resign well he
probably got super tired of being a
school principal probably trying to
party man but he did have the kids why
he's doing this
no a Cornell speech reporter first
responder Archambault gentlemen's club
to Washington DC shot DC and then talk
to a man refusing to pay his bill all
right dude oh you know I was telling
chin when I was in Cleveland you know
everyone told me all the local people
LeBron James doesn't tip
how crazy that really multiple people
are just like how we like a man but like
you're a bunch of like I've ate a bunch
of local shops all and they're not
associate alt only the same thing he's
gotta know that they're gonna talk
that's where they were that's what I
said but he's just so famous thing give
a [ __ ] I'll see you up a billion dollars
what do you get a la in that
mind-blowing tipped away Rogan tips is
that mind-blowing yeah what tip the way
anybody tips but it's crazy yeah that
disappointing bomber
what else she got this here Ashton
Kutcher just recently testified about a
murder did you know he was involved he's
a witness not not a witness to the
murder but a witness to someone that has
been murdered yes he was dating nope
wrong oh that's what he says so he so
the girl that he was going to pick up
was dating his friend they broke up and
he was gonna take out for drinks they
weren't they've never dated before
wasn't it oh and he was picking up for
the first time he was running late and
she goes cool that would get drinks so
he's like calling and texting her to see
you know where she's like hey I'm on my
way bum be late she's not responding
back sees that gosh she's probably mad
so he gets to the door rings the
doorbell and she doesn't answer anything
cuz she must be pissed I'm late
looks in the door sees red and thinks
it's wine yeah there's obviously tons of
blood and then laughed and it just
happened that she got murdered by the
serial killer who they had a house party
and the sirak serial killer was there at
the house party they came back in ops he
murdered her slit her throat so bad her
head almost decapitated and stabbed a
bunch of nice guy he thought it was wine
in the first place because they had
parties before and it was like reckless
so I figured it was just wine stains how
crazy after all these years in kitchen
so astron creature freaked out because
his handle yes around the doors are good
far as he tried getting it so he was
like oh [ __ ] that girl died my
fingerprints on the door so he called
the police like young I was there
supposed take on a date
those are not my fingerprints can you
imagine me in a stirring kitchen don't
have to testify against the serial
killer and this wasn't this isn't 2001
mm-hmm
this is 18 years ago dude before anybody
knew him
no he's still famous doing what was he
yes yeah that's of these show yeah that
one it was on yes many famous baby yeah
he's so rich now cuz he got an attack
like Twitter and all I'm one of the
original investors himself he's rich
richer he's amazing yeah yeah speaking
of Ashton Kutcher this principal pretty
much like plagiarize Ashton's entire
speech from I think Nickelodeon yeah
Nickelodeon teens Choice Awards this
person so one of the students put this
together to see how it's pretty long but
I think it's really fascinating to watch
it and he did he spice it up yeah oh
please let me see that this is really
good and the principal saying that he
didn't copy it but he took sort of like
the you know outlined yeah conscious
what do you know yep verbatim you only
changed one word the first thing is
about opportunity
the second thing is about being
intriguing here we talking life really
amazing things that I learned when I was
Chris and I wanted to share those things
with you guys because I think it's
helped me be here today so it's really
three things the first thing you're an
opportunity Sexy's only word he changed
he said intriguing huh the kid goes
here's my principal plagiarizing his
entire kitchen sweets Kiko opportunity
looks a lot like hard work when I was a
kid growing up I didn't get paid to do
chores I had to do them I had to run the
vacuum cleaner that's the house clean my
room cut the grass when I became fifteen
I had to get my first paid job working
as a busboy so I could pay for my own
insurance to help drive the family car I
didn't have my own car nor was i given
one the family had to share it then I
got a job working as a waiter then I got
a job selling shoes in the mall then I
got a job being a literal speech
jingles up and down a ladder to a roof
and cleaning up job sites sometimes I
even did more than job oh he copied all
this I won almost to a team for
part-time jobs like going to college and
the greatest thing about that was that I
never had a job in my life that I was
better than that I was too good for I
was always lucky to just have a job and
every job I had was a stepping stone to
can't wait to see us in kitchens and I
never quit my job until I had my next
job and so opportunities for me what kid
was like hold up I've heard this so
first opportunity oh no I believe that
opportunity looks a lot like hard work
when I was 13 I had my first job when my
dad carrying shingles up for the roof
then I got a job washing dishes at a
restaurant oh my god job in a grocery
store deli and then I got a job in a
factory sweeping cheerio dust off the
ground and I've never had a job in my
life that I was better than I was always
just lucky to have a job and every job I
had was a stepping stone to my next job
and I never quit my job until I had my
next job and so opportunities look a lot
like work for me what a piece of [ __ ]
it's hilarious though the most
intriguing or the most attractive or the
most interest the principal's not gonna
get fired is the world I don't think so
I think he's just gonna be embarrassed
like dude that's called it I love what
some kids like did I've heard this
before
you [ __ ] up son dude I this just
reminds me cuz we're watching a clip you
know what today's price so nervous if I
can't speak and they just what I'll use
this as a blueprint what do you think
someone just skate it'll break the
principle that's the problem no you
gotta know yeah principle I was in 2001
oh no this is recently but the this this
speech was 18 No whatever no whenever he
did in Nickelodeon the merge toys thing
though 2013 was Nickelodeon so I had to
do press in Cleveland and I went on this
like morning radio show you know ever
this lady who's a dime piece and before
I went on there like you know we've had
some other counts on here dude
this [ __ ] guy and Bobby Lee's
interview that when they're doing press
will make your day it's so funny they
don't want to be there and because I
don't want to be there either wait do
you see this I eat it chin go to this
the comic is so funny cuz doing press
yeah I want this guy's my spirit animal
this morning to impress because you can
tell he's hungover it's live and it's
[ __ ] keep going I say this guy's my
spirit animal and then there's a link
keep going keep it moving
should be keep going boss
nope keep going it could be that tweets
and replies right wherever all my [ __ ]
that dude this is the front page yeah
but yeah let me do this it's so funny
it's the greatest I would have bought
his tickets should have all sold out and
the lady so she don't know what to do
she doesn't know what to do what day did
you do it I would have done on Friday
now I'll see it
keep going janitor be on there and all
the comics oh there it is this yeah okay
mark mark Normand welcome back here a
nudie Cleveland it is time for a little
bit of a laugh we need consumer live so
be here at hilarities this weekend so
welcome here into the studio it's good
to have the pleasure I'm a little
hungover a little gay but life here with
you sister
well I appreciate you saying that I'm
very happy to be here with you two all
right sorry
hiding my erection but
yeah great I know you just loves Lyman
yeah that's Lyman so I'm really gonna be
on the toilet later boy best corned beef
and in the Midwest if you ask me it's
delicious it's the size of your head
yeah yeah and I ain't way to much but at
least everybody there was very
attractive no I'm kidding but good good
good grub there oh I bet you are
yeah I've been farting it up in the
grease the door was little shut yeah
we're a little smaller green room
exactly have we called hotboxing really
soaking it all in is it the smell of
your own farts or something this is live
do people give you farted to be weird
but if I fart I'm with this guy thing
you could hear no woman would ever say
something like that no it is more of
maybe a queefing coffee so yeah we're
all adults here
you live you City now but you're from
New Orleans yeah well well done you're a
grinder by looking you up yes yeah but I
know that clean ones fortune but I know
for you guys and that was I know that
was that was brutal we really thought we
had it you know New Orleans all we do is
drink and go to strip clubs we really
needed this win you know but no dice
right they're so close
yeah always next year right yes but we
get one of these every you know since
you seen it's been Norman
so I live in New York now that was what
yeah it's worse it's worse
did you just recently move in with a
lovely lady I bought a place I got a lab
moved in with a lady and Alexa oh really
Oh
oh yeah she's a track of everything and
she gets mad when I talked to Siri yeah
bought my place I own a piece of the
rock in Manhattan it's the only thing my
parents have been proud of that I've
done I've done The Tonight Show Conan
Colbert Comedy Central but when I bought
my apartment that's when they actually
started answering my phone calls but hey
that's why I'm a comedian cuz I gotta
get loved somewhere so but for you I
mean yeah so getting into this business
35 not that young but you know not on
the viagra yet where am I I like to
snort it said quicker [ __ ] awesome
he's in New York I love this dude yes
please don't you love them I went down a
whole rabbit watching oh dude I went
down a rabbit hole watching all the
stand-up I'm so sad watching fun of
course is a sad day now go to Bobbie Lee
where she's a savage it's all your same
thing no I didn't post biology's really
but I posted that when Mark Norman's my
spirit animal do impress this morning I
posted that and then they said the
hilarity goes make sure watch Bobby
Lee's and then tag the lady and the
ladies actually really cool about the
host yeah she's super okay
it wouldn't be on Bobby Lee's profile
where would it be on YouTube bro Oh
chintz aren't gonna pose as you totally
hung in there though wait do you see
what Bobby Lee I'm surprised you didn't
get in trouble for this
yeah do Bobby Lee yep there you go there
it is Sekulow sucks yes a year old yep
okay so he went to post that over this
one
excuse me kissing yeah
you're never clean and proper okay I'm
gonna have a girlfriend that's the
questions okay getting uncomfortable ask
the questions do your job Natalie thing
what what is it Natalie I like you you
use Whitestrips be honest it's not real
they can be real if I lived in Cleveland
you and I yeah the team okay boys
thank you hold are you know I'm 86 what
was that confidence and I have this um I
just want to go for it you're in rain
and uh look at her just it never works
she doesn't like ethnics no so does that
mean if this is maybe in the morning yes
yes working out those making it it
doesn't feel like it is no yeah your
energy is like it's a little too strong
I have a legend ship is going really
good really yeah how long have you been
together four years
it's strong it's really straight yeah
and she's way better than you
she's I've never seen him before I did
let me just tell you the boat did come
off I don't care is it always do they
always come on I don't live in from
Samara I live in my own America and I'm
gonna get naked then fine he's done
America I hope funny is that he's
amazing he's so funny how he kills me
that mark Normand though oh my god dude
you go to Vegas I know sorry am i or am
I like to snort it kicks in faster she
goes you look good eos black don't crack
that was the best one she's so great
that she's awesome
there's no sand every like yeah every
comic goes to her there's a whole loop
of comics with her huh it's fun it's
amazing
hey get the [ __ ] outta here all right
kids that was great that cracked me up
and that good one yeah see that dude
love you dr. mark
yeah come see me this weekend
Indianapolis IN do see buys your own six
seven eight go saygus the 15th me and
Brenda do 50 tickets left wrong and then
we can be happy I got happy June 20 21
22 get your tickets Tempe improv let's
go yeah fat cake um I'm at flappers this
Saturday one night once you're only
shopping friends right it's me
Rappaport Fahim and a song that's one
night when show only a flappers then
Vegas with Kalin like he told your asses
50 tickets left
see Kalin pratik Allen perform did see
him and myself perform together
I think Calgary I'm at Yuk Yuk's Calgary
June 23 to 22nd that's gonna be a fun
when I love Calgary I'm definitely in
that Chinese food of the casino getting
sick ah Brea then Brad you hear that
during that I think it's gonna be me and
some friend Brad come on down Brad in
private Brian he's with me
Brian June 27th through the 29th Brahe
improv get your tickets now tea fat cake
ah that it dude yep we're moving Studios
y'all yeah not yet though a few weeks
are in our studios we're on some new
[ __ ] some new bigger chairs still gonna
be red but there'll be bigger uh-huh big
you're bad or stronger that's fighting
the kid thanks for listening we love you
this the fine kid route yeah